[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and this video
were breaking down all the confirmed in
rumored Marvel characters coming to the
MCU throughout this video we'll be
discussing the x-men Fantastic Four
Doctor Doom and a lot more as we are
going over some leaks and surprises that
may be some spoilers here so if you
don't anything ruined then I highly
recommend that you turn off now we are
discussing some of the rumored reveals
in Black Widow and the Disney Plus shows
so this is your last chance to back out
if you don't want to know anything you
still here then make sure you subscribe
to the channel and please drop a thumbs
up as it massively helps us out without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our breakdown of every
Marvel character coming to the MCU for
phase 4 and 5 ok it's the first film
that's kick-starting phase 4 is Black
Widow though this is set straight after
Civil War it still contains a lot of
brand new characters that we haven't
seen before the movie reportedly centers
around the Red Room a training facility
that Natasha herself went through that
specializes in female assassins we will
be getting introduced to Natasha's
allies including Yelena Bulova played by
Florence Pugh Red Guardian played by
David Harbor and Malina Buster cough
played by Rachel Weisz it's rumored that
Bulova will be taking the position of
widow in the Avengers since her death
and endgame and that she will be a big
focus in the movie Red Guardian is a
Russian Captain America that didn't
quite receive the same sort of a claim
that his counterpart did and apparently
Vostok off is a former black widow who
ends up betraying the group in order to
secure the Red Room she is the big bad
that will be in control of taskmaster
who is rumored to be played by ot [ __ ]
Ben ley who is also playing Rick Mason a
former ally of shield that was once
romantically connected to Natasha
according to a 4chan leak we will see
firsthand the characters that taskmaster
has studied and these include the Hulk
ant-man Black Widow Hawkeye Steve Rogers
and more however it also states that
there will be a list that mentions
characters we haven't seen before such
as James Howlett aka Wolverine Wayne
Wilson
aka Deadpool
moon night and Ghost Rider Ghost Rider
did appear in agents of shield but it
has been said that he will be dropping
into the MCU movies as its own character
though we don't know whether this will
be a recast or not Ray Winstone is also
playing Drake of the head of the Red
Room that is rumored to be the father of
Natasha and the man that started the
project up next is the Eternals and
these characters are all people that we
haven't seen before in the MCU at all in
the MCU the Eternals are going to be an
immortal alien race that were created by
the Celestials and they've lived
secretly on earth for seven thousand
years they initially disbanded but are
reuniting to protect humanity from their
evil counterpart known as the deviance
which are the same race that done our
stems from as for the lineup we have
Richard Madden as the most powerful
eternal Jemma Chan is Cersei who falls
in love with Dane Wittman aka Black
Knight played by Kit Harington they're
said to be the main focus but alongside
them is Kumail Nanjiani as king go a
cosmic powered eternal that becomes a
Bollywood star to blend in lauren riddle
off is Macari a speedster that's also
deaf there's also Brian Tyree Henry who
is playing fastest and he will be the
first gay superhero in the MCU salma
hayek is a jack the leader of the group
though if you know the comics this will
likely change
Liam Q is an eternally young member
known as sprite Don Lee is a powerful
eternal known as Gilgamesh Mary Kieran
is drugged and lastly is Angelina Jolie
as Deena who is a brave and fierce
warrior we don't know the ins and outs
of the plot yet due to their currently
being no trailer but it is rumored that
we will be seeing a young Thanos in
flashback the next film to be released
is shang-chi and the legend of the ten
rings as I'm sure you can guess this
will be introducing shang-chi who is a
skilled martial artist that has been
tasked with taking down the Mandarin see
Mali is heading up the role as the
titular character and Tony lawang is
playing his opposite we've already seen
the Mandarin in the MCU however it is
said that this film will reveal the real
Mandarin a gangster that's angered over
how his name was taken and repurposed by
Aldrich Killian and of course the
lovable lovable Trevor now there are
rumors that this movie will actually
connect to endgame namely the Hawkeye
scene in which we see him taking down
the Yakuza
according to leaks the Mandarin rose to
power after the snap happened and this
was actually his gang that was
slaughtered
he wishes to now get revenge and
shang-chi has to stop him
the Mandarin may also turn out to be
shank Chi's father but that's a rumor
and we'll have to see how it plays out
now there's been a sort of reshuffling
and we don't know for definite whether
this will be the case due to delays but
up next is apparently spider-man 3 the
film will reportedly feature the debut
of scorpion and though we have seen as
alter-ego in homecoming it's been teased
by Michael mando himself that we will be
getting his more let's say colorful
sight according to leaks on Morbius the
scene in which the titular character
bumps into Adrian Toomes he asks him to
join the team that he's setting up and
this is of course the sinister six the
six will make their grand entrance in
spider-man 3 and this could feature a
lineup of vulture Scorpion carnage
Kraven the hunter possibly venom and
even more now there's a lot of theories
and not much confirmed but it is
possible that Norman Osborn could be
making his debut too it was said that
the character was due to appear at the
end of far from home and even a visual
effects artist said that they'd worked
on the scene but this as of yet is
unsubstantiated with Tom Hollands
signing on to do six more MCU movies
there are a lot of directions that they
can take the character and I definitely
hope that we see The Osbournes popping
up in some form or another
up next is thaw love and thunder which
will be the fourth solo film for the
character we know that Christian Bale
will be featuring in the film as its
main villain yet as of now we have no
idea who this is
other notable things in the movie are
that Jane Foster will be taking up the
mantle of door and cor will be dropping
by as well as the guardians of the
galaxy beta ray bill is rumoured to
debut in this too and it may see the
appearance of the as guardians of the
galaxy and finally in the face for movie
lineup that we know for definite is
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness this has had a reshuffle or the
change of directors
and it will reportedly feature the
villain nightmare and a link into one
division which we'll talk about in just
a bit according to the wiki on the movie
Wonder will be the person that sets off
the multiverse of madness and the film
will also tie directly into Loki as for
the Disney Plus shows the Falcon and
Winter Soldier is Saturday beyou u.s.
agent who will be a government-appointed
version of Captain America one division
is debuting Wiccan and speed the twin
children of the pair that both have
amazing abilities lastly is Loki which
will feature the introduction of the TBA
aka the time variants Authority the TBA
are basically an agency that stops
timelines and universes from spiraling
out of control and they lock Loki up in
order to stop the version we saw an end
game running amok it's also rumored that
we'll get the introduction of Nathaniel
Richards aka Kang the Conqueror but who
will play him is unknown as of now I
don't know if it'll be Owen Wilson
but yeah either way Kang is amazing and
it's gonna be interesting to see now
before we get into the phase five
announcements I just wanna let you know
we're giving away a free copy of the MCU
infinity Saga box set to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the characters in the
comment section below but when it's
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
July and the set will be shipped out
from then - ever gets the price it's the
best of luck - everybody takes part ok
now up next are the characters that
we've had confirmed will either be
introduced in phase 4 before getting
their own films in phase 5 or ones that
we've heard rumored to be debuting we do
know that Mahakali will be playing blade
and this was announced last year at
Comic Con to rapturous applause black
panther 2 is also currently in
production and it is said that Namor the
Submariner will be featuring the film as
one of the main villains before he
becomes an antihero it was lip service
paid to an underwater earthquake and
endgame and is rumor that this will be
the event that brings Namor into the MCU
after Atlantis goes to war with Wakanda
as for the antagonist according to
Charles Murphy this will be Doctor Doom
who has risen to power in between the
five-year time jump in endgame according
to the site Victor Von Doom will be
expanding his empire
conquering parts of Africa and
ultimately come into conflict with the
nation of Wakanda
and the Black Panther doom is one of my
favorite MCU villains I definitely think
that they can do a hell of a lot with
him my opinion Dallas wasn't that
complex of a character in the comics but
he did some incredible things with him
in infinity war and I'm sure they could
match that with a movie centered around
doom now at the aforementioned Comic Con
Kevin Feige did announce that the x-men
and Fantastic Four were indeed coming to
the MCU this opens up a lot of avenues
and possibilities for the future now we
did recently hear that John Krasinski
and Emily Blunt had both been in talks
with marble though they did not say what
role this was for however you don't need
to be Reed Richards to figure out that
it was probably well Reed Richards and
Sue Storm they of course could go head
to head with doom and I would love to
see them facing off against their
classic villain as for the x-men and
recent behind-the-scenes photos of
Falcon and went to soldier we can see a
flag for Matt rapport which is a key
location in the franchise this is
teasing their arrival though we don't
know how they will be brought across
just yet now I have a fan theory that
we've already seen one member of the
x-men in the universe and that is
mystique the shapeshifter who I think
will have been blending in as a
character this entire time it would
completely pull the rug out from under
everyone's feet and know this is just a
fan theory it's something I'd absolutely
love to see as it would come as a huge
surprise and the characters we know for
definite or miss Marvel she-hulk and
Moon Knight all of which were confirmed
at comic-con by Kevin Feige it's also
been teased that Nova will be joining G
to an Easter Egg and far from home and
it seems like the company are lining up
a lot of Disney Plus shows and films
alongside one another so we've got a
constant supply of content to keep us
going I just hope this stuff isn't
delayed any more as yeah there's a lot
of things going on in the world but we
know these things are coming eventually
and it really feels like Marvel are
gonna have a second win soon with so
many of their big names now being part
of the universe obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the characters and
which ones you want to see the most
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please drop a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of the latest episode of
agents of shield which is gonna be
linked at the end if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate you and it's a
thank you you get access to content
early
you wanna come chat just after the show
either follow us at heavy spoilers or
click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with the channel
and hopefully we see over there very
soon if not have a lovely week and take
care yourself
much love
[Music]